by apple expo à la porte de versailles
c'est le rendez vous des inconditionnels
du macintosh 120 mille visiteurs sont
attendus et le salon s'ouvre cette année
dans une ambiance particulière pour la
première fois mcintosh s'associe avec
son ami de toujours bill gates et
microsoft l'autre système d'exploitation
informatique une révolution au pays de
la pomme avec yvan est loin et olivier
tu y es tu
c'est une marque un produit mythique qui
rassemble des dizaines de millions
d'euros mais les créatifs pour reprendre
le jargon des mac maniaque le macintosh
créé par un inventeur de génie au fond
d'un garage de californie a permis au
commun des mortels d'utiliser un
ordinateur en toute simplicité
vingt ans plus tard la pomme est mal en
point écrasé par le monde pc est lié à
microsoft la société de bill gates pour
ne pas disparaître apple a donc décidé
de faire un mariage de raison et de
signer un accord avec l'ennemi d'hier se
procure une excellente nouvelle
la meilleur poste c'est que la bourse le
jour de la noce l'action apple a pris
33% dans la journée il faut que ça
montre la confiance des investisseurs
est ce que je peux vous dire aujourd'hui
c'est que les utilisateurs parmi les
traits d'un professionnel extrêmement
confiant l'âge de guerre enterrée apple
a donc décidé de se replier sur les
marchés où elle reste en bonne place à
savoir la création l'édition et
l'éducation
apple présente d'ailleurs cette année le
cap du troisième millénaire un micro
ordinateur baptisé le leem est
entièrement pensé pour les écoliers de 8
à 18 ans
ça peut remplacer une partie du contenu
du cartable à savoir les enfants dans
leur cartable qui souvent très lourds
ils ont des livres qui concerne
l'ensemble de l'année scolaire alors
qu'ils n'ont besoin que de trois ou
quatre pages ou peut-être dix pages qui
pourrait être résider dans la machine de
façon très simple pour uniquement la
semaine à venir
autre produit vedette du salon le mac os
après microsoft et son windows 95 la
pomme sort en français son nouveau
système d'exploitation une vraie
nouveauté selon les dirigeants d'apple
qui ont développé des technologies et
l'internet et augmentait la déjà célèbre
convivialité du système pour les mac
maniacs mac os 8 n'a rien d'exceptionnel
mais fidèle à la tribu apple ils sont
déjà 1 me
deux cent mille aux états unis elle lave
racheter prison